[Music]
scientists are struggling to uncover the
true identity of dark matter
to date the best candidate is a
theoretical particle known as a wimp but
because wimps can pass through ordinary
matter like a ghost the researchers have
been left and be handed not only could
Dark Matter to be going through me right
now but almost certainly is and I'm just
not noticing it and this is why we're
building these very fancy detectors here
on earth to try to catch them until
scientists can capture and analyze a
wimp all bets are off the main challenge
for the wind theory is that we simply
haven't found any wimps yet and we've
been looking pretty hard for a lot of
years and pretty soon it's gonna start
to get embarrassing perhaps dark matter
isn't made of wimps perhaps the stuff
that makes up dark matter is stranger
and more complex than we ever thought
possible
we know that regular matter comes in
many different forms there are electrons
and protons neutrons quarks all of those
why should we assume there's only one
kind of dark matter
our approach could be all wrong instead
of looking for a single type of particle
that could be an entire zoo of dark
matter particles
particles of ordinary matter interact
with each other to form atoms and
molecules the stuff we touch and see if
dark matter is made from different
particles it could do the same
interacting and building dark atoms of
dark stuff perhaps even a universe of
dark materials
if we can show that dark matter
interacts with itself that means there
really could be dark matter galaxies
Dark Matter stars dark matter planets
and people all around us right now that
we were not aware of